Washington journal continues we want to
welcome back to c-span independent
senator Bernie Sanders of Vermont
appreciate you being with us good to be
with you three a couple of Senate votes
today on different budget plans what's
going to happen probably both of them
will lose and then we're going to have
to get down to some serious business
about how you move this country forward
in deficit reduction in a way that is
fair to working families in the middle
class the major concern that I have in
terms of HR 1 which is one of the
Republican House bill that will be voted
on it is just draconian in terms of the
cuts that it made in this day and age in
the middle of a recession when somebody
working people are hurting the
Republican plan would throw over 200,000
kids off of head start I'm not just
moving in exactly the wrong direction we
worked hard to expand community health
centers so that more Americans low and
moderate income people can have access
to health care devastate that I can tell
you that in my office and I think in
Senate offices all over the country
people who are applying for Social
Security of a disability benefits are
waiting too long they would devastate
have devastating cuts in the Social
Security Administration making it harder
for people to get the benefits that they
need thirty percent cut in the
Environmental Protection Agency when we
have to be vigorous and protecting the
water that we drink the air that we
breathe and on and on so these are cuts
on education cuts against the poor cuts
against the sick cuts against the
elderly at a time when the richest
people I'll be doing much much better so
to my mind it is just morally
unacceptable that you would balance the
budget on the backs of of the kids and
the most vulnerable people in our
country while at the same time giving
tax breaks to millionaires and
billionaires that's what the debate is
about and yet you've heard from the
Republicans who have argued that over
the last two years we've seen a huge
increase in government spending let's
bring it back to the 2007 levels what we
have seen is that when Obama became
president we were on the cusp of a
worldwide depression the collapse of our
financial institutions we
losing 700,000 jobs a month so it's
unfair for the Republicans to say oh gee
we've spent a lot of money sure we did
we passed a stimulus package which put
between two and a half and three million
people back to work rebuilding our
infrastructure and doing a number of
things which i think our country long
needed so to say that trying to work our
way out of a severe severe recession it
was the wrong thing to do I disagree
with so my view is that when we have the
most unequal distribution of income and
wealth in the entire industrialized
world with a top 1% now earn more income
than the bottom fifty percent and Steve
if you can believe this and I know it's
not talked about very often the top 400
families in this country that's not a
lot of families 400 own more wealth than
the bottom fifty percent of families in
America so that gap between the very
very rich and everybody else is growing
wider the middle class is collapsing our
job now is to focus on rebuilding the
middle class creating decent paying jobs
and moving to a deficit reduction in a
way that is not on the backs of the most
vulnerable people in our nation we're
going to get to your calls and comments
in questions in just a moment the
numbers will continue to be on the
bottom of the screen or you can send us
an email or join us on our twitter page
at twitter com c-span WJ in case you
missed it yesterday senator your
colleague Senator Joe Manchin Democrat
from West Virginia had this to say on
the Senate floor more important question
is this why are we engaging in this
political theater why are we voting on
partisan proposals that we know will
fail that we know don't balance our
nation's priorities with the need to get
our fiscal house in order why are we
doing all this when the most powerful
person and these negotiations our
president has failed to lead this debate
or offer a serious proposal for spending
and cuts that he would be willing to
fight for senator Sanders well I would
hope that the President does engage in
this important discussion but i will
tell you steve that the reason that i
was on the floor in december for eight
and a half hours is that the cop
my so-called compromise agreement that
the president worked out with the
Republicans was to my mind a disaster
what the president agreed to was
extending the Bush tax cuts for the top
2% actually lowering the tax rates on
the estate tax which only apply to the
top three tenths of one percent so we
gave a significant tax break to not just
the wealthy but the extremely wealthy we
extended tax breaks for the rich in
terms of dividends tax a capital gains
tax that was the agreement that the
president reached now I hope that the
president comes forward and I hope the
president says that in these very
difficult times when the middle class is
struggling that yes we're going to move
forward toward deficit reduction but we
do it in a way that is fair and if the
President does that I we delighted to be
supportive of it I hope that he does it
I'm not quite so confident that he go
we've been trying to explain this to our
audience but we're talking right now
about the current budget which will
expire at the end of September the
president last month putting forth his
budget for the next fiscal year which
begins October first I just want to put
a couple of numbers on the table senator
and get your reaction a 3.7 trillion
dollar spending plan 1.1 trillion is
borrowed money and 250 billion dollars
is used to pay off interest on those
payments no question let's talk about
that this I think that's a huge issue
does this country faced a significant
national debt problem with 14 trillion
dollars and a deficit problem which is
1.6 trillion let's back it up just a bit
Steve how do we get to where we are
number one less revenue is coming in
because we're in the midst of a severe
recession everybody agrees on that so
most importantly is how do you
revitalize the economy create jobs put
millions of people back to work so that
they're paying taxes that's the most
important thing second of all I find it
interesting I have to say this that many
of the quote-unquote deficit hawks many
of the guys that are yelling loudest
about this issue are precisely the
people who helped cause the deficit
situation women right now now you recall
yum you were here behind the camera when
we went into this war in Iraq all right
did you hear too many p
say oh my goodness we can't go into this
war in Iraq unless we pay for it I
didn't hear one word about that i voted
against going into the war in iraq for a
number of reasons one of them being is
that this war is going to end up costing
us some three trillion dollars by the
time we take care of the last veteran
now i find it enormously hypocritical
for these same people who say that they
are so worried about the deficit we just
have to cut hundreds of thousands of
kids from head start we have to cut back
on heating programs for low-income
senior citizen we just can't afford to
do that what were they doing two months
ago they were fighting vigorously for
huge tax breaks for millionaires and
billionaires which obviously drives up
the deficit that's what they have been
doing Thea's so I don't quite understand
how folks can come in and say I'm really
concerned about the deficit oh yes but i
want to give huge tax breaks to
millionaires and billionaires when we
bailed out Wall Street I voted against
that by the way but I didn't hear any of
my colleagues Republicans or Democrats
who are now concerned about the deficit
saying we can't provide seven hundred
billion dollars in support to Wall
Street because that will drive up the
deficit we need a Norfolk offset so
Steve to some degree there's a lot of
hypocrisy about this and it really is
not focusing on in fact the serious
problem of deficit reduction we do I
have to deal with that a lot of it is
ideological a lot of what we are seeing
right now in the Republican bill that i
will vote against today is what they've
always want to do cut back on the needs
of working people give tax breaks to the
wealthiest people in this country allow
the loopholes we are losing a hundred
billion dollars a year because of
corporations and the wealthy stashing
their money in the cayman islands and in
bermuda tax havens outrageous you think
my Republican friends were concerned
about the deficit are going to go after
that they're not so a lot of this thing
is not just moving toward a balanced
budget a lot of it is ideological it is
forget the needs of the middle class and
working families let's worry about the
rich and the powerful one other set of
numbers and then we'll talk about your
book and get to our viewer calls and
comments looking at the discretionary
spending in mandatory
spending of the federal budget you've
seen the figures but it's about 36 or 37
percent that is discretionary the
mandatory programs that you talked about
Social Security Medicare Medicaid
accounts to about fifty seven percent of
the budget and interest on the debt
accounts to six percent and growing so
as you look at those numbers where do
you cut even if you increase taxes where
else do you cut well there are a lot of
ways that you can cut now for example
health care everybody agrees whether
you're a conservative or progressive
everybody agrees the cost of health care
is outrageously high but let's ask
ourselves a couple of questions today in
America we have 50 million people who
have no health insurance we have about
45,000 people who are going to die this
year because they don't have access to a
doctor that's the fact and yet at the
end of all of that health care costs in
America today are almost double that of
any other major country on Earth you
know that almost double why is that why
is that now one way you can solve that
problem is to do what some governors are
now third let's throw low and moderate
income people off of Medicaid well
that's fine just throw more well if
you're 50 years of age and you develop a
lump in your breast and you don't have
any health insurance what do you do but
you could go I guess that's one option
or you go to the emergency room and they
send you to the hospital who's going to
pick up that bill well you want people
with insurance are going to pick up that
bill that's one way to go the cost of
health care is soaring we got 15 million
people without any health insurance now
I think the health care reform bill that
was passed last year takes us somewhere
someway in the right direction but it's
nowhere near enough why do we spend
twice as much per person on health care
as any other nation and yet our outcomes
are in many case not as good as some of
the European countries or even Canada
and the answer is that we have private
insurance companies in the midst of all
that whose function in life is not to
provide quality cost-effective health
care to the people it's to make as much
money as they possibly can I introduce
legislation calling for a
medicare-for-all single-payer national
health care program but have a lot of
support you sheron's companies needless
to say very much against it but I do
want to say that in my state of Vermont
now we have a governor I think we have a
legislature that are prepared to lead
this country forward in a
medicare-for-all
payer program we already have some very
authoritative studies which tell us that
that will save hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars when you get
insurance companies out of it when you
get all of the administrative costs
associated with what we now have a very
confusing bureaucratic system the goal
of health care is to provide quality
health care to all people in a
cost-effective way not do what we're
doing so when you talk about the cost of
Medicare and Medicaid that's one issue
you have to talk about second issue
Social Security I am getting very very
tired of seeing my political friends or
the pundits tell us Social Security is
going broke so let me be very clear
Social Security is not going broke what
social security is under attack right
now from people who have always wanted
to destroy Social Security who basically
believe that the government should not
play a role in providing retirement
benefits to the elderly or help for
those people with disabilities will help
with widows and orphans who have lost
their breadwinner and in their family
social security today has a two point
six trillion dollar surplus doesn't
sound like it's going broke to me Social
Security according to everybody who has
studied at Social Security
Administration the CBO can pay out every
benefit owed to every eligible American
for the next 27 years Social Security
has not added one nickel not one nickel
to our deficit like the country so when
people tell you that you've gotta cut
back on benefits and Social Security you
have to raise the retirement age of
social security or maybe we have to end
Social Security completely let's
privatise it let's do our retirement
accounts through wall street I very
strongly disagree with that and I resent
that Social Security has accomplished
exactly what the founders of Social
Security wanted it to accomplish before
Social Security fifty percent of the
elderly in this country we're in poverty
today that number is ten percent and for
the last 75 years in good times and in
bad you know three years ago millions of
Americans lost their retirement savings
they lost their homes they lost their
jobs because of the wall street
engineered crash you know many people
lost their social
purity benefits nobody not one person
for 75 years Social Security has paid
out every nickel Oh to every eligible
American that's a pretty good record and
I know there are people want to destroy
Social Security this senator will fight
to preserve it yesterday before the
Senate Budget Committee you were part of
the proceedings senator Alan Simpson
your former colleague from Wyoming a
Republican the co-chair of the
President's Commission on the debt and
the deficit had this to say about Social
Security Social Security is not a
retirement it was never intended as a
retirement it was an income supplement
after the depression the average age of
life was 63 and that's why they said if
retirement age of 65 the beginning of
the greatest Ponzi of all time now the
life expectancy is 77 there are 16
people paying into this system when I
was at the University of Wyoming and one
taken out then there are 10 paying him
today there are three people paying in
and one taken out and in 10 years there
will be two people paying in and one
taking out how long do you think that
kind of things can sustain well it's a
good speech and all the facts that he
gave may or may not be right but it's
totally irrelevant in 1983 Reagan and
Tip O'Neill sat down because Social
Security in 1983 was in the midst of a
real crisis it was a crisis not like it
is the name today we can pay out every
benefit for the next 27 years I didn't
hear senator Simpson talking about that
reality the fact is that in 1983 an
arrangement was reached between Reagan
and the Democrats and that agreement by
and lodge has worked pretty well so
where we are right now which mr. Simpson
forgot to mention is we have a two point
six trillion dollar surplus now what's
the answer we can pay out every benefit
owed to every eligible American for the
next 20 years so we're not in a crisis
situation but what the actuaries you
know these guys who sit around with
their within numbering pads they want to
figure out is how it is good for the
next 75 years and I'll tell you what I
think the solution is and somehow
senator Simpson neglected to talk about
that and that is to do what Barack Obama
proposed when he was running for office
anything has repeated since and that is
right now
right now Steve if you make a hundred
and six thousand dollars you contribute
there's a cap on the amount of taxes you
put into the Social Security trust fund
so one person makes a billion a year and
one person makes 106,000 they both
contribute the same amount into the
Social Security trust fund what
candidate Barack Obama proposed which I
think makes a lot of sense is you have a
bubble you leave untouched income up to
250,000 so you're still at 16 level but
then after 250,000 you lift that cap and
all of that new income is taxed at the
same rate comes into the Social Security
trust if you do that social security
will be strong for the next I think 55
or 60 years and that's the solution to
the problem the book is called the
speech a historic filibuster on
corporate greed in the decline of our
middle class the morning of friday
december the 10th you woke up you went
to the Senate floor you started to
deliver a speech it became somewhat of
an internet sensation a lot of viewers
on c-span to a lot of Twitter followers
what happened well what happened is you
know many of the issues that I've been
talking about now where we're taking
place there we there was need for an
agreement on on taxes and the president
sat down and he negotiated an agreement
with Republicans which I thought was a
very very fair very unfair agreement
what the president essentially allowed
in that so-called compromise is the
extension of the Bush tax breaks for the
wealthy and again I find it
incomprehensible how people can talk
about deficit reduction when you
continue to give hundreds of billions of
tax hundreds of billions of dollars in
tax breaks to the very wealthy because
in your speech you point out that
President Bush when he took office
inherited a 236 billion dollar surplus
in 2001 and a projected ten-year surplus
of five point six trillion dollars so
when President Bush came into office
that's right after the Clinton
administration we were going forward
toward huge surpluses effect and you may
remember they were great debates I was I
was not in the Senate
but in the house as well what are we
going to do with all that surplus should
we give tax breaks to everybody right
now should we use it to infrastructure
for infrastructure should we use it to
strengthen Social Security there was a
great debate of what we can do all this
money that was lying around well
needless to say we don't have that
debate anymore but one of the reasons
that we are in a deficit situation is
these huge tax breaks that go to the
wealthiest people it's country right now
and you've heard I think many of the
viewers I've heard people like Warren
Buffett Warren Buffett is one of the
richest guys in the world and Buffett
points out that his effective tax rate
effective tax rates right now is one of
the richest people in this country is
about sixteen percent that is the lowest
effective tax rates for the rich that we
have seen for decades and Buffett makes
the point that his effective tax rate
now is lower than his secretaries it's
lower the most teachers nurses doctors
cops firemen does that make any sense
corporate tax rates have gone way way
down you have a situation where a few
years ago ExxonMobil made 19 billion
dollars in profit ExxonMobil most
profitable corporation in America not
only did they not pay anything in taxes
they got a it was 156 million-dollar
refund from the IRS you have large and
profitable corporation after Lodge and
profitable corporation paying nothing in
taxes so clearly if we are serious about
bringing an element of fairness into our
society in seeing the middle class get a
fair shake we need to ask the wealthiest
people in this country and large
corporations to start paying their fair
share of taxes we're talking with
senator Bernie Sanders he's the former
mayor of Burlington Vermont former
member of the House graduated the
University of Chicago he serves on among
other committees the Budget Committee
which held a hearing yesterday we showed
excerpts with the co-chairs of the
president's bipartisan Commission on the
debt dennis is joining us from Kansas
City Missouri Democrats line good
morning welcome to the conversation good
morning thank you for c-span senator do
you know the percentage of children in
Head Start low-income people that
contributes a political campaigns or
vote well i think dennis you you hit the
nail on the head down
when you have here we have and this
really galls me because the childcare
any working family in America will tell
you how difficult it is to get quality
affordable childcare and years ago as a
nation what we said look we have the
highest rate of childhood poverty in the
industrialized world over twenty percent
of our kids are live in the body and we
understand every psychologist every
teacher will tell you that if kids don't
get the intellectual and emotional
nourishment that they need by the time
they get to kindergarten by the time
they get the first grade they are ready
behind then we're looking at twenty-five
percent of our kids dropping out of
school kids getting into drugs into self
destructive activity and we have more
people in jail than any other country so
what we decided to do is to say look low
and moderate-income kids let's help them
let's give them quality early childhood
education through head start now the
caller what Dennis is saying obviously
is that Republican friends want to throw
over 200,000 kids off of head start how
much money do their parents contribute
into the political process well needless
to say I expect very very little and
dennis is right a lot of what takes
place right now only made worse I should
tell you by the Citizens United decision
which will allow corporations and
billionaires to put disclosure is that
big money calls the tune in Washington
DC has an impact not only on the
Republican Party I would tell you on the
Democratic Party as well text has this
point to your 400 wealthiest families
don't those families give back in spades
by creating all the jobs and inspiring
so many to strive for excellence
somebody want jobs do they create jobs
well some of these people inherited
their wealth some of these people do
create jobs some of these people are
throwing American workers out on the
street many of the largest corporations
in this country and I'm sure that some
of these CEOs are heads of the largest
corporations have in fact downsized very
substantially in America and moved
collectively millions of jobs abroad all
that I'm talking about you I'm not here
to attack wealthy people all I'm talking
about is that we need a sense of
fairness in America and as a nation
right now with our middle class
virtually disappearing and
Papa D increasing the idea that 400
families own more wealth than the bottom
fifty percent of families in America is
frankly obscene it really is
indefensible and in terms of job
creation what we do know is that most of
the large corporations in this country
in fact are employing fewer Americans
now than they used to because they have
outsourced our jobs to china in other
countries so I don't quite accept that
argument Abdullah is joining us from
California are aligned for independence
with senator Bernie Sanders good morning
good morning sir I'm and I missed I
you've ended your last segment before
they before I could be on the air so but
i first have a critique for c-span and
then I had a quick comment for certainly
Sanders I stopped I was an avid watcher
of c-span and I stopped watching after
the last presidential election I think
c-span because you're the only outlet in
America now where the American people
actually get a chance to hear each other
every other modem of the media is there
speaking to us what I'm offended by
would c-span and you have the
responsibility when you have these
people up there one of the reason why
I'm an independence because I'm only
interested in the truth I'm not
interested in a label or anything like
that but you all let those Republicans
sit up there say Obamacare they tell all
their lives that guy that you had on
before Mr Sanders was a complete and
total disaster he wasn't well spoken or
anything I need you guys because you
know the fact you're reading the
newspaper and everything you're
intelligent people when these people are
up there telling absolute lies that's
why the country is divided you have a
hand in that so what questions should we
had asked well I'm just saying when you
know that they're saying actual things
that are completely factually wrong you
have a responsibility we need you as the
American people to correct that we
depend on c-span and hope i will do that
but obviously you say we don't we have
too much time i want to say something to
mr. Sanderson Mr Sanders I have watched
you I America needs more individuals
like you in our positions of leadership
I love your truth I love your
fearlessness I watched you in different
media and every single time you're very
consistent I have much respect for you
sir and you are the exact opposite of
the gentleman that was there before you
the people are just interested in truth
and we're Pinter's in people who are a
passion and fire in their bellies
they're trying to fight for the people
we love I love you and I'm sure I'm just
one voice speaking for many ok I'm going
to challenge your comment now to senator
Sanders I'm just kidding abdellah that's
very that's very kind of you and thank
you very much let me just say this um I
one of the things you asked why the
speech that I gave went all over the the
internet and was picked up so much on
Facebook and all of that and I think the
answer is there are a lot of things
going on in our country which are not
talked about in the corporate media or
the right-wing media and I think the
average person out there whether you're
Republican Democrat progressive
independent whatever you are they know
that something is wrong and they know
that the middle class for whatever
reason is collapsing that people today
are working longer hours for lower wages
than they used to they're worried not
only about themselves they're worried
about what's going to happen to their
kids and if we don't turn this around
Steve our kids are going to have a low
standard of living then we are from your
speech I December the 10th you said
quote what motivates some of these
people is greed and agreed and more
green there is no end to it so what they
do is things like hire lobbyists who are
all over Capitol Hill these lobbyists
sometimes former leaders of the
Republican Party former leaders of the
Democratic Party former hotshot lawyers
bright people their job is to make sure
legislation we pass such as this major
tax bill that this legislation benefits
not ordinary Americans but those who are
wealthy that's why the fact is and and
that's the point how much does somebody
really need look I I have no objection
they're always going to be people who
are rich and always going to be people
who are poor but do you really need to
hire all kinds of lobbyists spend huge
amounts of money in campaign
contributions in order to make another
couple of hundred million dollars when
is enough enough you know throughout the
history of America they're always been
visions between the people who own a
company in the people who work but you
know what you're seeing right now is
many of these major corporations who are
running profitable businesses here in
America they say I don't make enough
profit here in America so I'm going to
throw out i'm going to lay off thousands
of workers move to china not because i
can't run a profitable business in
america i can make even more money by
paying people 50 cents an hour was 75
cents an hour so the point that i make
there which i think a lot of people
agree with is you're looking at folks on
the top incredible greed it appears that
no matter how much they have its it's
not enough the rich get richer their
taxes go down they get huge numbers of
tax breaks in terms of wool street for
example and let me be very clear we are
in the midst of a horrendous recession
horrendous recession where if you look
at the real facts unemployment is not
eight point nine or nine percent real
unemployment is closer to sixteen
percent when you add to those numbers
people have given up looking for work
people who are working 20 hours a week I
want to work 40 hours a week this
recession was caused by the greed and
the recklessness and illegal behavior on
Wall Street and every day when i go back
to Vermont i hold a town meeting we just
held one on saturday got 500 people out
people say how come none of these guys
in Wall Street who performed illegal
acts not one of them has gone to jail so
that's one of the questions from our
viewer when are we going to have justice
for what he calls those Wall Street
crooks well there you go right that's
why I hear all over the country and you
know what the Wall Street crooks are too
powerful and they ain't going to get
justice because they pretty much own the
Republican Party they have a lot of
influence in the Democratic Party what
should have happened after these crooks
destroyed the economy a month later we
should have had what was called a pakora
to commission pakora was a guy who in
nineteen 32 or 33 work with the Senate
investigating what went on in Wall
Street and where people the crimes that
these people committed the damage that
they did to our economy how many people
lost their homes their jobs their life
savings because of the crooked the
business model which is fraudulent on
Wall Street but they are too powerful
apparently to be taken to justice and
that's a sad state of affairs Carl is
joining us republican line from
hedgeville west virginia good morning
yes good morning you know as long as you
set there and filibuster you'll never
have to answer many questions from
conservatives because you know you sit
there and talk for 20 minutes and nobody
else gets in but I want to tell you a
little story I was raised up in southern
West Virginia during the lyndon
johnson's great society program well
what happened we soon learned that the
government would send us a check the
more kids we had the more money we would
get they would send us food we didn't
have to get out and hustle for food so
therefore we could lay on the couch all
day and you know live the good life now
you see I was fortunate i joined the
Marine Corps and I got out in this world
not seeing that the harder you work the
better off you are and you know you're a
good man you're a compassionate man but
socialism will not work in this country
and you know it if you take away and
center for people to work people won't
work and and that's just the way it is I
mean you know look stop filibustering so
much and let other people ask you
questions about conservative isn't thank
you all right let me answer calls and I
didn't know that I was filibustering him
but call the idea that the American
people kind of don't want to work I've
heard that be but I'm not going to tell
you for one second that there are in
people out there who will exploit the
system you know we will get food stamps
against some other program and what it
not the work it is true but i think the
number of those people is much
overstated the truth of the matter is
that we live in a country for what ever
anybody around the world may say about
America we are the hardest-working
people in the world and what I want to
say to call is a few years ago we had
the dubious distinction I think of
surpassing
the Japanese in terms of the number of
hours our people worked we now work the
longest hours of any people around the
world and I could tell you that in my
state of Vermont it is not uncommon for
people not to be working one job but to
working two jobs three jobs occasionally
for jobs in order to cobble together an
income and call there is nothing that I
have said to suggest I do not think that
people should be working and that people
should be working hard and there is one
of the frustrations that I happen one of
the things that I talked about in my
speech is that right now with
unemployment as high as it is there is
an enormous amount of work to be done i
don't know about west virginia like
pretty sure it's true there to tell you
in Vermont we need work done on our
infrastructure that's our roads our
bridges our culverts our public
transportation or water systems we can
put over a period of time millions of
people to work rebuilding our
infrastructure which makes us more
competitive so I think please don't hear
me to suggest that we don't want to
encourage people to work and I think in
this country people do want to work this
speech was eight and a half hours it
began when on the morning of December
the tenth a little bit after ten o'clock
and you yielded at about seven or so and
it's now turned into a book it's called
the speech Bernie Sanders a historic
filibuster on corporate greed and the
decline of our middle class one of our
viewers who tweets this question senator
Sanders please comment on the Wisconsin
Union fight also the influence of people
like koch industries in politics good
what the book is about and what my
speech was about was not only my
disagreement about the tax agreement
reached between the president and the
republicans which i thought was a very
unfair agreement it is what is going on
to the middle class and working families
of our country and as i mentioned
earlier Steve in my view and I think
most viewers no matter what their
political persuasion is will agree our
middle class is collapsing in America
and the gap between the very rich and
everybody else is is growing wider and
there are a number of reasons for that
one of us is a disastrous trade policy I
think that's NAFTA permanent normal
trade relations with China other trade
agreements which have basically allow
corporate
arca to throw American workers out on
the street move to developing countries
with people that sometimes pay pennies
an hour and then bring their products
back into America and it becomes much
hot and out of fine products made in the
United States of America we have lost
millions of good-paying jobs another
part of the reason the middle class is
in decline and not unrelated to the
trade issue is fewer and fewer people
are members of trade unions ah what a
trade union is simply about is bringing
people together so that they can
collectively standing together negotiate
with their employer a fair contract what
is going on in Wisconsin today is part
of the assault on the middle class and
what we're seeing now is a governor
every Wisconsin Vermont every state in
the country virtually has serious
deficit problems and each state is
trying to deal with that but breaking
unions and ending the ability of workers
to bargain in this case public employees
to negotiate contracts has nothing to do
with deficit reduction it simply is an
effort to destroy your political
opposition make it harder for working
people to stand together to get a fair
shake so I think what's going on in
Wisconsin is not unrelated to what's
going on here in Washington there are
savage attacks taking place against
working families in the middle class
when you give tax breaks the middle to
billionaires and you cut back on
community health centers the night
people access to health care well throw
kids off of head start or cut back on
Pell grants at a time when middle-class
families are desperately trying to get
their kids into college these are all
attacks against the middle class then
the caller asked well what about the
Koch brothers and these guys what is
also going on and this is where the
greed element comes in is the Koch
brothers and then I certainly unique are
now in a position through the disastrous
Supreme Court Citizens United decision
to put as much money as they want into
the political process they can run TV
ads in Wisconsin Vermont any place they
want without any disclosure because the
Supreme Court said that they now have
unlimited First Amendment rights to get
involved in the political process so
what you're saying now is the very
wealthiest people many not all not at
all
you have a lot of wealthy people say you
know what I'm worried about my country
I'm worried about the children in this
country don't give me tax breaks a lot
of folks saying that but not all got a
lot of other folks who say hey I'm worth
35 billion which is what I think the
Koch brothers I need more and more and
more let's work together to break unions
and so forth so what you're looking
about is not only the wealth of the of
the big money interest getting bigger
but you're seeing their political power
growing as well Dorothy is joining us
from Wisconsin in delafield on the
Democrats line good morning good morning
I just want to say that I do like the
format that the c-span run like the fact
that guest speakers can have their say
and there's no interruption with opinion
from the facilitator I want to talk to
mr. Sanders regarding what's going on in
Wisconsin here and I listen to a lot of
what you have to say I'm I am a Democrat
but I I guess I i feel i'm an
independent Democrat and former teacher
former principal just watching what goes
on what's going on in this state in
terms of the governor attempting to
break the unions and I think as an
extension to that interrupt the flow of
support financial support for
politicians that represent I think the
middle class I want to thank the
gentleman for standing up and speaking
the truth that's why I listen to a
c-span and I want you to just continue
and I hope that people of the middle
class will start to do it more of what
has happened here in Wisconsin voters or
citizens standing up and really being
citizens and showing the world what
democracy looks like in action Thank you
Thank You Dorothy very briefly let me I
mean what I agree with what are they are
saying what you're seeing in Wisconsin I
think goes beyond if you like what's
even going on in their own state I think
people are sick and part of the assaults
taking place against the working
class they don't want to see public
employees played off against private
employees I know the governor there is
saying well look at people who are
probably at private employees they don't
have this they don't know that the
answer is we want the middle class to
expand we want poverty to go down we
don't want to say you know to keep
attacking each other in a race to the
bottom so the idea that you have in
Wisconsin now teachers and public
employees and firemen and police
officers standing together to say hey
we've got a we've got to protect the
middle class against continued results
is I take a very positive development
you're an independent from Vermont
you've been called a liberal a
progressive a socialist where would you
put your political ideology well I am I
am on the ballot I've always run since I
was elected as mayor of Burlington in
1981 as an independent and I am very
proud that the people of Vermont have
given me the opportunity to serve mayor
is in the house and now in the Senate I
am the longest-serving independent in
the history of the United States of
America Steve I'm an independent because
I think that some of the callers have
suggested today money plays a huge role
in our political process influencing
both political parties I come from a
family that never had a whole lot of
money to struggle with money I think the
job of those of us who are elected is
not to worry about the needs of large
multinational corporations and the
wealthy but ordinary people who today
are really really hurting so I'm proud
to be an independent I am progressive in
the sense of what goes on in Scandinavia
western europe i'm also a Democratic
Socialist I think as I indicated the
growing inequality in America is
something that concerns me I believe
that everybody in this country is
entitled to health care is a right
education is a right we've got to do the
best we can to create decent paying jobs
have a fair tax system as President
Obama met your expectations two years
into his term in general no in some ways
yes I think in the president we have a
guy who is incredibly smart incredibly
articulate I think he has done some very
very good thing
I think that the plate that he inherited
when he came in it was just unbelievable
in terms of the financial crisis losing
700,000 jobs a month very very difficult
stuff and I think he has done some good
things I was a strong believer in the
stimulus package I would have liked to
have seen that package be even greater
he and I worked together in one area
that I think is very significant we're
not going to get a handle on health care
in America until we greatly expand
primary health care until we make sure
that everybody in this country has
access to a doctor so they don't end up
going to the emergency room they don't
end up getting sick and ending up in the
hospital it great personal suffering as
well as great expense to the system he
has been very very strong on that effort
we are going to double the number of
community health centers in America
provide health care to 40 million people
in that area and he and I work together
and that he's been strong in terms of
trying to move us away from fossil fuel
to energy independence and sustainable
energy but there are areas where I have
not agreed with them I think for example
the agreement that he struck with the
Republicans in terms of taxes was a bad
agreement I have been very concerned
that a lot of the people in the
financial area that he has brought into
the White House have come from Wall
Street have not been that represent the
middle class and working families I
certainly disagree with some of his
budget suggestions right now when he
proposes to cut LIHEAP in half which is
the low-income heating assistance
program my state the weather gets 20
below zero I got a lot of senior
citizens trying to just stay alive on
thirteen fourteen thousand asya we
should not be cutting that program so
you know it's a mixed feeling to him
some good things something that's a good
things our conversation for those of you
listening on c-span radio is with
senator bernie sanders independent from
Vermont he's out with a new book called
the speech the text of his eight and a
half hours address that we carried live
on c-span two on the Senate floor on
December the 10th Matthew is joining us
from Glasgow England go ahead please
actually when I Scotland good morning
Matthew hello I was going on I just
wanted to ask the senator what he thinks
about us not putting more money into
education and things like that
I think it's insane I mean we already
have an educational crisis in this
country and when I hear my Republican
colleagues talking about cutting back on
Pell grants which is the major source of
federal funding to help low and moderate
income kids get a college education when
I read that there are states like Texas
and other states prepared to lay off
around our country hundreds of thousands
of teachers clearly everybody
understands that if you're going to make
it into the middle class today you need
a good education it is likely you need a
college degree clearly everybody
understands that we are losing a whole
lot of kids who are dropping out our and
we need to increase our educational
capabilities not diminish them in one of
the areas by the way that we're working
hard on it doesn't get a lot of press or
attention but we have a real crisis in
child care in this country and if you
are to income family and most
middle-class families now have husband
and wife both working how do you provide
good quality childcare for your kids and
an affordable cost well it doesn't exist
in many places in America we've gotta
focus on that we got to treat our child
care workers with respect and we're
working on legislation we've introduced
legislation to address that so I don't
think you cut teachers and cut back on
education but James points out that more
money has not resulted in any
improvement in education I think you
also have to reform education as well
there's no question about that but to
say that we should throw teaches fire
large numbers of teachers make our
classroom sizes even larger or throw
hundreds of thousands of kids off of
Head Start is not a help and to say that
money does not correlate money is
important too I think you have got to
paint if you want to attract the best
and the brightest young people you can
have to pay them a good salary and we
also have to address the fact that the
cost of college is so high right now
that a lot of young people are given up
even on the desire to go to college not
to mention others graduating deeply in
debt Fran from Oswego New York has this
question the good senator sounds like
he's making the case for a flat tax or
consumption tax would you ask him what
he thinks about the fair tax bill no I
think the fair tax bill which says as I
understand it that the tax rates for
millionaires and people making 25,000
should be the same would be a real boon
doggle to the very very well I believe
in progressive taxation clearly the tax
code right now is out of control
enormous numbers of loopholes that most
of which benefit our the wealthy and
large corporations like give you many
many examples ExxonMobil being just one
on many of large corporations that pay
nothing in federal income taxes so we
need a simplified system but in my view
those people earn more money I should be
asked to pay a higher percentage of
their income in taxes and from your
earlier point George has this to that
caller from West Virginia socialism
worked pretty well for bankers in Wall
Street but one of the points that I make
somewhere in the book is that in many
ways we have a system of socialism for
the rich Wall Street is that is the case
in point so here you have all over
America small businesspeople family
farmers in my state and elsewhere
desperately in need of affordable loans
they can't get it but yet if you are the
largest financial institutions in the
world that have been involved in illegal
activity you're getting massive bella
and one point that I want to make Steve
is one of the things I put into the
financial reform bill is an audit the
Fed in terms of their emergency
provisions that took place during and
after the crash and what we discovered
because the Fed made that available a
few months ago is people say well the
top that seven hundred billion dollars
800 billion we use to bail out Wall
Street was only a small part of what
took place what also took place is three
trillion dollars in very low interest
loans that went to every large financial
institution when the companies like
General Motors went to foreign central
banks all over the world so what you had
is a perfect example of socialism for
Wall Street and for the very rich and
rugged free enterprise for small
business people and working people David
is joining us from Baltimore good
morning welcome to the conversation
David good morning senator Sam
I remember watching a video of you on
YouTube where you were questioning Ben
Bernanke of the Federal Reserve and
being completely astounded when you
asked him where the people's money went
if he could tell you exactly where it
went him and he straight up said no to
you I just that really struck true to me
about how secretive and how powerful the
Federal Reserve is but getting to some
of your comments earlier you have
continued to speak about the greed of
Wall Street and the big business and big
corporations however the greed that I
see that is actually destroying the
country right now is the greed in
Washington of you perhaps yourself but
maybe not yourself but certainly your
colleagues there in the Senate and in
the house you guys continue to spend a
lot more money way too much money more
than what the federal government
legitimately brings in every single
month and you guys want to always raise
taxes on the whip on the wealthy or
whoever to cover the expenses of your
increased spending in Washington why
can't the federal government simply live
within its means why can't you guys
simply spend what you take in every
single month which I've heard is around
two hundred billion dollars a month
thank you David okay David let me answer
you you talked about the Fed yes I did
ask Bernanke where the trillions of
dollars went he said he refused he
refused to tell me we introduced
legislation to make him tell me that
legislation was included in the
financial reform bill and eventually
that came out and that was less just
what I was talking about a month ago
three trillion dollars going to every
financial institution logic in this
country many large corporations many
individuals as well in terms of spending
within our means yes i agree i ran a
city for eight years we took in money we
spent the same amount as we took in we
had a balanced budget should we be doing
that yeah but when you're in the midst
of a recession and you have a whole lot
of people who are hurting there are
investments that you have to make it is
wrong
my view to say that we should be
throwing hundreds of thousands of kids
off of heads thought for one example of
many so to answer your question is that
a budget is two things it is spending it
is bringing in review I do believe as I
said a number of times this morning it
is absurd to give tax breaks to people
who don't need it and then cut back on
programs for people who are desperately
dependent upon those programs senator
Bernie Sanders independent from Vermont
and out with a new book from his speech
on December the 10th that we covered on
c-span to the speech a historic
filibuster on corporate greed and the
decline of our middle class thanks as
always for being with us good to be with
you appreciate your time coming up in
just a couple minutes we're going to
introduce you to our grand prize winner
and c-span's student cam contest and
also more information on many of the
entries but first to look at the latest
news from c-span radio it's 28 past the
hour this just in the Board of NPR news
has fired CEO Vivian Schiller in the
wake of a video sting by a conservative
activist and US Vice President Joe Biden
speaking to business leaders in Russia
to a management school calling on Russia
to attack corruption and improve its
legal system the vice president also
supporting Russia's attempts to join the
World Trade Organization and while the
vice president travels in Russia
President Obama and first lady Michelle
here in Washington and today they've
posted a video on facebook to promote a
bullying prevention conference that
they'll host at the White House tomorrow
in a taped video message the president
says that bullying should no longer be
treated as an unavoidable part of
growing up and those are some of the
latest headlines on c-span radio
you